I don't believe that men and women are
fundamentally interchangeable that's the
same reason why I don't believe that men
should be able to beat up on women and
mix martial arts competitions or be able
to smash World Records and powerlifting
for the same reason that I don't believe
men who are just out of their minds
should be competing against other guys
who decide to play by the rules go start
your own trans the organization no one's
persecuting you we just don't want you
beating up women why namely the [ __ ] and
balls question of the day clearly if you
were a parent and you saw your daughters
having their opportunities taken away or
just having the crap beaten out of them
having to compete against trans athletes
how would you react really let's get rid
of just the progressive agenda or where
you line up politically how would you
react if you were a parent sincere
answer I want to hear from you this is
what we call segue vice just did a video
on how evil the USA powerlifting
Association is because they discriminate
against trans lifters at a powerlifting
meet in April assets of all shapes and
sizes showed up to lift heavy they were
all relatively in Congress except one
the benchpress the spot what's her name
is JC and she's trans for supports the
whole life and at a young age even had
Olympic ambitions and curling ice bowler
direct competitive advantage what was
your reaction disappointment and also
like not in being surprised entirely
because of the way that trans women and
trans feminine people are treated okay
okay get some science here but I don't
know what trans feminine is I'm pretty
sure if I were to say it at eight speed
that's Jelena we're supposed to say MTF
transgender not not not allowed to
compete is what it is yeah they forced
to sit on the sidelines okay we need
this person who was a man not allowed to
cook why wasn't this person allowed to
compete name of the [ __ ] and balls
that's why to do it right the idea that
the USAPA but they've been banning trans
lifters it's not right in the first
night a couple of reasons they already
discriminate okay based on age range
allowable medications some aren't
proved and they're doping policy which
yes includes testosterone you can't take
it if you want to compete with this
organization there are tons of other
roles by the way we need to be clear
about down to what kind of t-shirts or
hats you can wear whether you can wear
hat at all during competitions that's
how sports work yeah but they have rules
yes exactly their whole point is to
ensure a fair competition they're not
looking at somebody who has long hair
and looks like a man and says that
they're a woman and says I just don't
like that and even though they're not
talking advice there were probably a lot
of people who were complaining that it
wasn't a fair competition well why is
that name of the [ __ ] and balls Mexico
do you think it's fair for you to
compete in the women's category
absolutely why why not
balls growth that would be the primary
reason I hope I've crystallized than
three but more so what comes along with
the Wang and meatballs that's really
what it we'll get to that in a second
why there's a difference and it doesn't
change just because you stick a needle
with estrogen in your ass once every
other trans people meet all the rules
they'll just establish more rules to
govern our bodies and like our
participation in society and in sport
yes there's gonna go burn your body no
they are a governing what is this is
this your honor I'm gonna judge me now
you're gonna judge me now same argument
it's my body for the ringing endorsement
next clip Katrina
carcasses is a bioethicists who works on
testosterone and sex testing Rizzoli
when they make the case do transmissions
have an advantage over six women in
sports of strength like powerlifting
people want to make these broad
generalizations trans women have an
advantage but it's always going to be
much more complicated than that
not really I use that term loosely
because this bioethicists which Katrina
what's her name Katrina tree is
something after just forgotten it cases
doesn't have a degree in biology or even
an MD PhD in anthropology take a quick
glance at this person's Twitter feed
they're Connie
they pushing the kaepernick taken knee
okay I'm saying this doctor's not a
trans ena this woman yells at Trump when
he comes in the TV excuse anyone who
disputes this idea of transgenders in
sports of being a part of the patriarchy
this is someone with a vested interest
in a social agenda by the way if a
notification bell if you're subscribed
because doesn't mean a whole lot I just
bookmark the page with videos every day
join up at mug Club letters credit home
/ mug Club of course subscribe on iTunes
also this is important to know this is
not a scientific and we'll get to this
in a second and we can rattle off the
science within one minute but if you
look at even the International Olympic
Committee that's what the IOC yeah they
talked about how their trans policy is
based on social political change not on
science they don't even require you to
go through a sex change operation how to
compete in the Olympics oh my gosh just
have to have been taking female hormones
for one year I think up here yeah think
of how dangerous that is in greco-roman
all right next clip
testosterone mm-hmm does it influence
sports performance it does so it is
related to things like lean bodies but
it's not necessary or sufficient to push
an athlete to be at the top level so you
can't assume that the people with the
highest levels of god watch your own do
better I love how advice of what
Katrina's saying is that there's no
clear link between testosterone and
sports performance she said there is a
clear link but just doesn't guarantee
for example that like weak male fat ice
bowlers will be the best female trans
lifter in the history of mankind
but basically what she's saying though
what you're really saying is there's no
clear link there testing let's go
through some just rattle off some of the
advantages that come to mind uh height
bone density fast twitch muscle fibers
in surprised me I learned this window
doing research for this lung capacity so
there's one beta everyone we're height
goes without saying men are taller than
women longer it doesn't go away when you
inject hormones it's a huge advantage it
works like basketball or combat sports a
little bone density men have greater
bone density than women obviously for
high impact sports is better for them to
have greater bone density
may have some effect but not really of
course fast twitch muscle fibers men
have more fast which muscle fibers and
women I think that the advantages here
in sports would be self-explanatory no
not at all and that's why even if you
look at ROI de doubt female power
lifters they still trouble lifts as much
as a natural and the lung capacity
surprised me when you actually have
greater lung capacity I didn't know that
I didn't know that either but it stands
to reason before by the way you say that
this is why we actually need to
transition kids at a lower age they
don't have all these benefits hold you
for that that's child abuse okay sorry
none of these advantages are wiped out
by hormone replacement therapy the only
one you could argue is bone density that
you'll lose some bone density if you've
been undergoing hormone replacement
therapy for a very long time but even
then for people with doing high impact
sports and weight resistance training
their whole lives you wouldn't lose that
much bone density to completely wipe out
the advantages all right quick
comparison by the way my supply woman
squat record said let's run this video
seven hundred pounds just bring it up
there Garrett we can we have this kind
of b-roll oh that's a woman's world
record that's very impressive obviously
very nice it's fantastic and then the
man's is a little bit more of a
difference by the way if you if you
remove the drug test was the u.s. APL
drug test and you go to Federation's
that don't they also lie use the squat
suit and adventurer people who don't
follow powerlifting you can't touch the
bar to your chest with a bench shirt
unless you have 300 pounds like it's
that much tension
give me a forklift let's see how much
but it goes to 1,200 here's a clip so
you can
to get his depth there okay yeah I feel
like he's gonna have back problems later
whoo let's burn out of his nose Yeah
right goodness there's a slight
correlation between testosterone and
strength it would seem because you see
the demands lifts and much more and then
you see when the men get on tip more
testosterone yeah they lift that much
more the gap goes 300 something to 500
something pounds well here's why let's
let's kind of look at some of the
numbers here I'm gonna be a little
scientific little nerdy for you the
mid-range male testosterone level for 25
to 30 years old about 670 nanograms per
deciliter
okay so here's something that's been
conducted where men who were on steroids
okay 600 milligrams of testosterone
every week yeah resulted in test levels
of 2,300 oh wow so that's a lot more now
that being said you can have some men
who have testosterone levels without
steroid any surge of it being about a
thousand nanograms per deciliter yeah
that means that a doping male athlete
that guy right there who's setting the
world record compared to the other guy
who is not on juice allegedly right they
they dress 3.5 times more testosterone
yeah which lastly is enough to have
people banned from sports for life
potentially right certainly get that of
competitions and records taken away
right three names like Jose Canseco a
forehead better raise the ceiling
mid-range female testosterone levels I
want to make sure I get this right
yeah about forty two point five
nanograms per deciliter so that means
the average met Tran feminine the
average male who would they would say
just let's not go with the transgender
male would have roughly seven to twenty
three times
the testosterone of a normal woman so
that guy if you're gonna get mad at that
guy for juicing and setting a world
record that we have in a different
category because they don't drug test we
don't even know who's on steroids or
who's not we just assume that they are
right if you're going to be mad about
that guy competing with other men in
Olympic weightlifting events or any kind
of Olympic event or any kind of athletic
endeavor don't tell when it's only a two
and a half times Jen have multiple yeah
hormonal advantage to another man don't
get all high and mighty and tell us that
there's no difference when this someone
has seven to 23 times the hormone
advantage it's not even close next clip
vice but what about JC how good is she
mrs. we asked her coach do a man look at
that so he's a great athlete and she's
strong
skilled lifts her in her weight class
she's not yet a standout lifter maybe
because she's a fat weak man is that
what the mean is that lot those who
don't get any numbers what's your total
there what's it Janine what's her name
it's JC
I don't the question is not whether this
lifter is particularly mediocre and or
unattractive okay
mediocre male athletes consistently
transition women and they not getting
first place in competition even becoming
world champions yeah right here Rachel
MacKinnon world cycling championship
Laurel Hubbard won New Zealand gold
medal national championships Mary
Gregory smashed for powerlifting world
records in a day today
nice so just because you were ripped
like Ike not all male athletes not all
men without with testosterone they're
not all going to beat every single woman
now we get it some are fat and weak more
curlers before hand that being said it
doesn't change the dish in a rule
alright another clip and so what I will
be doing is a timeout line meet by
standing up with you for one minute for
each of my three attempts
[Applause]
okay this isn't solidarity maybe in
powerlifting
some angry lesbians can take a timeout
in protest and you think that's cute all
right but this isn't the only sport
where this is happening
for example I'm sure that these actual
woman getting concussed would have loved
to have taken a timeout
[Music]
your intolerance is showing that is a
brave strong beautiful woman causing
repeated concussive syndrome to other
women will smith gonna line up for
casting into that one all right let's go
to the next clip we deserve a place in
sports too the bottom line is that even
in the fundamental principles of
Olympism they recognize that sport is a
human right Olympism do trans people get
human rights and the answer is yes no so
and i don't get you in racing I support
the First Amendment Second Amendment of
course these are actual human rights not
the ability to compete in any sport by
the way when you just when someone comes
out and says healthcare is a human
rights yeah but you said train ZZZ
competing and female powerlifting was a
right so I'm not really listening to the
whole human right train anymore I'm not
exactly on board playing the sport of
course you have the right competing in a
sport while flagrantly disregarding the
established rule set is not a human
right this is the issue at large why
does this matter there's a greater issue
at play here ok they're trying to pass a
law making it necessary for all sporting
organizations to accept transgender
athletes regardless of sex the bill the
Equality Act it specifically outlines
that you are legally liable unless you
get on board wholesale what's the modern
gender theory which is not based in
science even according to the
International Olympic Committee they
said it was based it was largely
motivated feelings remember they said
give you an example same-sex marriage
wouldn't affect you wouldn't affect the
church and by the word is not about your
opinion on same-sex marriage about the
ramifications that we've seen since the
rulings for churches pastors even
private businesses who've been targeted
and they were told that they wouldn't be
targeted before then afterwards are
being sued and shut down because he
declared something a fundamental human
right so right now what are we looking
at I don't believe that marriage is a
fundamental human right I don't know
that I mentioned recognizing marriage
because I believe that it's a privilege
to contract to people enter into and
right now when you're talking about
sports unless we get on board with this
new policy which by the way not only
could cause irreparable harm to the
fabric of society obviously very real
physical harm to women in
this is this is um it's it's really one
of those scenarios where it shows you
how tone-deaf Vice is they come and go
what they're clearly the rage there's no
correlation between testosterone and
performance and even the most
progressive podcast hosting beta males
are going to come on really you're
expecting us to get on board with this
entirely this is this is this is also
another example of saying that men and
women are fundamentally interchangeable
listen there's a reason that we have men
and women in different sporting
divisions for this this is for the same
reason that we recognize a man and a
woman as ideal in a marriage doesn't
matter what your opinion is but these
were fundamentally they would
fundamentally outline roles in society
because we believe that a mother and a
father were very important to rearing
children when you say that two daddies
can do everything that to a mother and a
father can do you're saying well that's
really nothing intrinsically valuable or
unique to women this say I don't believe
that I don't believe that men and women
are fundamentally interchangeable that's
the same reason why I don't believe it
man you should be able to beat up on
women and mix martial arts competitions
or be able to smash World Records and
powerlifting for the same reason that I
don't believe men who are juiced out of
their minds should be competing against
other guys who decide to play by the
rules go start your own trans the
organization no one's persecuting you we
just don't want you beating up women why
namely the [ __ ] and balls hey there if
you like this video subscribe to the
channel or hit the notification bell do
it I'll wait a second do your that
little ding it actually didn't make a
ding sound I just did it happen while my
mouth was doing it and you thought it
was coming from your computer so that's
fun also there's some videos playing in
these boxes next to me go watch those
you might enjoy them you might not you
don't care